me start off with two herbs
made in America
made in America
let me stop let me start off with two
words this is the Reuben report how you
doing people I was gagging on coffee as
I said hello to you
I'm okay now it's October 12 2022 we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
Blaze TV subscribe get the notifications
whatever you gotta do uh should tell you
people we just found out that yesterday
was our biggest day in Channel History
some people are saying there's a rumor
going around town that yesterday was our
best show ever who am I to confirm nor
deny this rumor I'm just saying that's
what the people are saying out there so
I appreciate all the support good things
are happening and speaking of good
things uh this is actually remarkable uh
so you know this this horrific basically
category five it was a category for one
tick away from category five hurricane
hit Southwest Florida about 10 days ago
absolutely decimated the Barrier Islands
Fort Myers Beach Naples area moved up a
little bit but just true destruction but
but in true Florida fashion and and
thanks to our extremely competent
governor and just everybody all the way
down this state is rebuild building fast
super fast people have electricity
already they've got running water
they're already rebuilding houses and
Roads and the cleanup's been amazing I
mean trust me the media wanted to take
out DeSantis because of this thing
Charlie Crist the clown who's running a
basically a fake campaign for governor
against Governor DeSantis he would have
loved for a slip up or a death or
something the administration wanted
DeSantis to screw something up but it
has just been airtight perfect truly
remarkable what's going on here in
Florida I mentioned yesterday that they
rebuilt there's a small Bridge roughly
small bridge that goes to Pine Island
from the mainland which they rebuilt in
three days well then I saw this video
yesterday this is absolutely incredible
this is the three mile bridge from Fort
Myers to Sanibel that was crushed in
about four different sections and they
have rebuilt it there are Supply trucks
going to the Island right now and I've
talked often about how much I love
Sanibel and how much it means to me and
I just wanted to show you this because
the point of this is that when you have
competent leadership when you have good
people when you have a mission and
direction
and you hire people based on competency
and all of those things we can still get
anything done here in America or I
should I guess say we can still get
anything done here in Florida so I'm I'm
just so I saw that my heart was warm
like I am so proud to be a Floridian and
as I mentioned right when the hurricane
happened I'm going to go to Sanibel for
a couple days I'm already in touch with
a couple venues I found out that one of
my favorite restaurants Still Standing
we're going to try to do some shows from
there and put on a party and a
fundraiser and all that so we'll have
more info on that but I just thought it
would be a great way to set up today's
show because it's just it's just a
beautiful thing that that you know
disasters happen horrible things happen
but humans are freaking resilient and
that place and not just that Place Fort
Myers Beach and Naples and the other
baryons they will be rebuilt they will
figure out new ways through engineering
to build structures hire more with more
defenses against these hurricanes and uh
and it's just a beautiful thing and it
shows you that things can work things
still still can work despite it all
people but today that's not the theme of
the show today the theme of the show
today is a bit about this Ukraine Russia
Fiasco and really how it's interwoven
with the Democrats sort of screwing up
everything on every front thus what do
they have to do they either have to
censor us or call us racist you know I
have not done a tremendous amount on the
Russia Ukraine situation the 101 of it
is Russia which is a sovereign nation
invaded Ukraine which it was a former
Soviet Republic but is now a Sovereign
Nation you can't just invade another
country as you know the entire world
turned against Russia they kicked the
Russian hockey team off of the
PlayStation hockey game Connor do you
play the I know you're the PlayStation
guy right you don't play the hockey game
what are you playing what are you
playing you're playing baseball you're
playing baseball I don't think Russians
play baseball so I think you're good in
that department anyway the we're going
to dive into a little bit about what's
going on here because not only as you
know uh we are giving crazy amount of
money billions and billions of dollars
to Ukraine we don't know where that
money is going you may remember one of
my interviews with Rand Paul over the
last two months regarding uh could we
maybe get some receipts on this stuff
you know if you lend if you lend a
friend some money you might want to know
when the where the money's going and
what it when it's coming back to you
we're obviously not getting any of the
money back and we don't even have the
money in the first place but money we're
giving them weapons uh it's like who are
we giving the the money and the weapons
to it's a big freaking Fiasco and uh by
the way that that Putin guy not a good
guy uh and also has nukes uh so are we
just sort of teetering off into Oblivion
here that's what we're going to be
discussing today and then some media
reaction and and I'll show you a little
bit what happens when you try to talk
about uh maybe not going to war let's
see how the media treats you uh real
quick guys let's talk about fast growing
trees then we will get to it I don't
know about you but I spend a ton of time
making my house feel like home indoors
and out and that's why I love
fastgrowingtrees.com whether you're
looking to add some privacy shade or
natural beauty to your yard fast-growing
trees has in-house experts ready to help
you make the right selection with
growing and Care advice available 24 7.
the experts at fast growing fast growing
trees curate thousands of plants so you
can find the perfect fit for your
specific climate location it needs you
don't have to drive around to nurseries
and big gardening centers fast-growing
trees makes it easy to order online and
your plants are shipped to your door in
one to two days I love fast growing
trees as you guys know we just moved
here to Florida we just put up a whole
bunch of citrus trees and I am loving it
and we've got an avocado plant and a
mango tree loving it I can't recommend
them enough go to fastgrowingtrees.com
Reuben and you'll get 15 off your entire
order now through October 15th couple
days from now 15 off at
fastcoringtrees.com reubenfast growing
trees.com Reuben and now back to me
okay so what's going on here with this
Russia Ukraine thing uh well uh let's
give you a little insight from the daily
wire as to how Joe Biden's handling this
Russian invasion of again another
sovereign country and you really can't
do that in international relations
President Joe Biden warned that Russian
President Vladimir Putin was not joking
about using nuclear weapons in Ukraine
as the Russian military which was widely
viewed as the second most powerful
military in the world before the war is
suffering Battlefield losses in Ukraine
we have not faced the prospect of
Armageddon since Kennedy and the Cuban
Missile Crisis Biden said adding that we
have a direct threat of the use of
nuclear weapons if in fact things
continue down the path they are going
Biden's remarks come as a Russian
military train is reportedly
transporting equipment for the nation's
nuclear weapons program to the front
lines of its war with Ukraine sparking
fear years that Putin could be preparing
to use nuclear weapons okay so it's a
little unclear whether that Caravan was
actually carrying nuclear weapons but
the fact that the elderly man pretending
to be president said the word Armageddon
and is Raising alarms about a nuclear
war uh this is as the kids say
problematic did any of you sign up for
this is anyone really sure what's going
on there and really sure I know I'll
probably get kicked off YouTube and
Twitter for this weather zielinski is a
good guy or not do we know where the
money is going are we actually at War
now if we are funding a war right we're
handing them the cash and then they're
buying all the weapons and we're sending
them weapons and all the proxies have
weapons are we at War uh I don't know if
you guys know this but for us to be in
war the way it's supposed to work is
that Congress has to declare war the
president signs off on it and then we go
to war we've done none of that related
to all this I don't want to be in a war
I would also prefer not to have a nuke
dropped on a America or on Ukraine and
this is part of the problem all of these
people that were so excited so excited
to say Putin you bad man and he is a bad
man he's an authoritarian he censors his
own people he stifles to scent all of
those things by the way zelenski when he
took over in Ukraine he got rid of all
the opposition parties so he's not such
a great dude either but okay all of that
let's just we don't have to get into the
minutia of everything related
to Russia and Ukraine the point is that
suddenly we are talking about Armageddon
and nuclear war and you know one of the
things is when the guy with the nukes is
losing and and feels like he's cornered
uh he's still got the nukes so all of
these people that are running around you
know in the last two weeks it's suddenly
like see Russia's militaries falling
apart and they're taking all these
losses and they're going to lose and
it's like
uh well you know they still got the the
big gun you guys we're going to talk
about that or no
anyway what's happening now is there
seems to be this new move where if you
say anything about hey maybe let's not
go to World War III maybe nuke dropping
nukes isn't the best idea maybe let's
try to de-escalate this situation uh
then you get called the Russian stooge I
mean we went through this a lot of this
with Trump right you're you're a Putin
Patsy and the rest of it so Elon Musk
and you guys of course all know Elon
Musk our Modern Renaissance man who's
sending uh you know cars out into space
literally sent a Tesla out into space to
orbit around the Earth and build an
electric cars down here and burrowing
under Los Angeles to build tunnels and
all of these things and starlink and
neurolink and all of the stuff uh well
he put out a tweet regarding what a
Russia Ukraine peace deal could look
like so let's put this up so you put
this up as a poll then and the reaction
to it is super interesting so here's
what he proposed or here's here's what
he's offering in the poll redo elections
of annexed regions under U.N supervision
Russia leaves if that's the will of the
people meaning if Russia annexes certain
things but the people in those areas
want to be part of Mother Russia and the
UN signs off on it then we all just kind
of Let It Go and the borders are a
little bit different Putin gets a little
bit of a win and and that's it okay the
other option is Crimea formerly part of
Russia as it has been since 1783 until
khrushchev's mistake water supply to
Crimea assured Ukraine remains neutral
so these are what he's putting out there
is like oh maybe this is a peace deal
that will make sense there's some Annex
stuff uh crimea's back to Russia the
water makes sense and Ukraine isn't
technically at war with Russia anymore
so this he put this poll up and it got
2.7 million votes and again Twitter is
not a perfect place for any of these
things obviously but that's not really
what this is about 60 of the people that
responded said no this is not good
enough now that's sort of interesting
but now you may remember
when I chatted with uh Bill Maher a
couple well it was about a week and a
half ago but it just was released two
days ago
um one of the things I mentioned is how
the machine seems to always want war
right and there's certain people that
always suck up to the machine and in
that specific case I was talking about
Stephen Colbert so anyway watch what I'm
gonna do here that wasn't a total
non-sequitur Elon Musk puts out this I
it was just an idea he's just polling
people does this sound roughly like an
idea for peace well here is machine
comedian corporate comedian Stephen
Colbert going off on Elon for asking
whether we could have peace yesterday
Elon floated an insane new plan to end
the war in the most Elon Musk way
possible via Twitter poll so Russia gets
everything they want but in exchange
Ukraine gives Russia everything they
want
sounds like the kind of plan that
Kremlin would thank him for which could
be why shortly after the Kremlin thanked
him for it
really seems like musk is doing Russia's
bidding here explains why his latest
model Tesla
is potato
top Ukrainian officials clapped back at
musk's pole Ukraine's ambassador to
Germany responded off is my very
diplomatic reply to you hey hey
that's not right the Diplomatic reply
would be please
so you see there he's a perfect stooge
for the machine right first up he
misrepresents Elon musk's musk's
position it's not that Russia gets
everything they want he's saying if they
addict some of these places and the
people there want the annexation meaning
to go back into Russia and if Crimea is
once again part of Russia
would this be okay so that we don't end
up in a nuclear war he's not saying it
was necessarily the best thing and also
he was just floating an idea but machine
corporate comedian Stephen Colbert
basically wants you to think that Elon
Musk is a Russian stooge because he's
trying to figure out an off-ramp for
nuclear war again
Putin's got nukes and the guy when he's
losing what happens to an animal when
it's Kate when it's cornered right it's
wounded and it's cornered it can only
lash out so Putin needs an off-ramp here
you may absolutely hate Putin you may
think he's the worst dude ever you may
might hate Russia all of these things
could all be very legit you could think
he's a bully and he has no right to any
of that land or any of that stuff but
then there's also reality which is just
oh he's still got massive World altering
weapons uh well when I talk about the
machine and how the machine wants War
here is Joe Scarborough of MSNBC The
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC with a very nuanced take on what
people who don't want war really are
civilians hey freaks fascist freaks on
the right there is no moral ambiguity
here there is no comparison between
Russia and Ukraine and and you prove
yourself to be the fascist that you are
when you suggest the same the official
paper
you see what he did there so if you kind
of talk about hey can we figure out a
way out of this not just make it really
oh you're you're good and you're bad
again Russia started this thing you
cannot invade a Sovereign Nation and we
can talk about NATO at their borders and
we can talk about Ukraine giving up
nukes and all there's all sorts of stuff
that you can talk about historically but
the simple fact is if you look at this
thing and you go good guy bad guy and if
you don't agree with me and if you don't
join me on this road to World War III
and drop in nukes and usually when one
nukes drop another nuke's going to be
dropped
um then you're a fascist and a freak and
of course he does this while holding up
the New York Times and of course the New
York Times is not a newspaper it used to
be known as all the News That's fit to
print it's now all the propaganda that's
fit to print but he holds it up because
well I could hold up paper too I'm not
going to believe this I did this right
before the show I didn't even need you
to help me with this one guys you suck
Joe I put that on paper thus obviously
legit anyway the fracas with all of this
continued because a few hours after Elon
Musk put up the first tweet and then the
you know you saw the response and people
are angry at him and also I think the
poll didn't uh perhaps get the results
that he wanted right because more people
said no to it than yes so then he
followed up here you go he tried another
poll he said let's try this then the
will of the people who live in donbus
and Crimea should decide whether they're
part of Russia or Ukraine yes or no
meaning that if the people who live in
these areas that were once under Russian
control if they decide by referendum hey
we want to be back in Russia is that
cool well here he got results and the
first poll at 2.7 million votes this one
had 2.4 60 percent of people said yes
that may not make zelinski happy it may
not make the warmongers happy but
leaving it to the people on the ground
and I assure you guys I'm not going to
sit here and pretend I have every little
knowledge and nuance and I assure you
absolutely nobody on CNN or MSNBC does
about whatever like The Insider every
single person in Ukraine what they think
is best for their life and whether they
should be part of Russia and Ukraine and
all of those things anyway let's bring
this to the elderly man pretending to be
president because he did a very long
form interview with uh Jake Tapper on
CNN yesterday Jake Tapper is a Democrat
activist and they did a interview and
obviously it was heavily edited and they
don't do anything live and of course he
has notes and it's he's getting the
questions in advance and all of that
stuff but Jake asked the elderly
gentleman pretending to be president uh
if we would negotiate so we could avoid
World War III
look
we've taken a position I just did a G7
meeting this morning
the idea nothing about Ukraine without
Ukraine
so I'm not about to nor is anyone else
prepared to negotiate with Russia about
them staying in Ukraine keeping any part
of Ukraine Etc
oh okay so we're just not going to
negotiate it seems to me that if you're
not going to negotiate and the guy is
already in Ukraine and again you know
he's got the weapons and you know that
he has he needs an out here right so
let's say again no I'm giving No Quarter
to Putin here
a guy does a bad thing now he's in this
country now the world is going after him
he knows if he just loses if he just
says hey we're pulling out and we lost
and Russia lost and all that stuff he's
literally Dead Man Walking he will be
dead much like Gaddafi ended up dead in
Libya when a guy when a mob chased him
and literally a guy took a knife and
jammed it up his ass yeah there's video
of it it ain't pretty but that is what
would happen to Putin right and he knows
that if he loses it's like his the show
is over for this guy so so you have to
negotiate with him why would you not sit
down with him and say here's the
situation man uh NATO is not happy about
this the U.S is not happy about this
maybe you're a bit in over your head
doesn't sound like the military
operation is working the way you thought
it was Ukraine didn't just Buckle over
the world has rallied around them uh so
perhaps we should talk but no Joe says
we're not going to talk we're not going
to talk okay so you're guaranteeing that
this thing gets worse let's revisit Maya
now process in a week and see if the
thing is better or worse anywho what's
Joe Biden really concerned about because
they only talked about the war and
potential nuclear Holocaust for just a
moment or two what's he really concerned
about well it's climate because of these
incompetent buffoons who can't do
anything right here in the United States
if we just give them enough money they
will fix climate change and all that
stuff how much money exactly do they
need and how much have we given already
well Joe summed it up quite nicely we
passed the look what I ran on I said
we're going to deal with energy right
and and the energy problem we're going
to deal with the whole notion of global
warming we passed 368 billion dollars
worth of help which as the same Bankers
talk about that's going to bring them
billions a trillions 700 million dollar
billion dollars off the sidelines and
invest Phoenix can you roll back so I
can repeat exactly what he said there
guys we are going to somehow out of the
368 billion that we put into climate
change and I'm sure that'll stop you
know if you just throw cash at Mother
Nature she'll ease up you know what I
mean she likes cash okay but so we throw
368 billion at it and how what's the
return on it guys according to Joe Biden
we're going to get a billion trillion
times 50 million for climate change
wait wait I like I don't think that
would work on a calculator right there's
not enough numbers on there one more
time it's a billion trillion times 50
million for climate change that is a lot
of zeros like you gotta carry that one
you know the man is an idiot he is a
complete buffoon and an idiot but
um there are other people that are
realizing this besides me so the CEO of
JPMorgan Chase Jamie dimon and he's been
a big player in our economy for many
many years Joe Biden often quotes him as
a friend and someone that he turns to
for guidance and that understands the
economy and all that well even now uh he
is going Joe you're kind of screwing up
the whole freaking thing there have been
a lot of Lehman comparisons made in
recent weeks and months with regards to
the Fallout from the energy crisis you
are the only Wall Street CEO who is
around to navigate the global financial
crisis how worried are you about Europe
this winter given everything that's
going on in Ukraine and with the energy
Supply well I think we're getting energy
completely wrong which is you know ever
since this war started you've known that
Europe is going to have a problem and
that it was pretty predictable that
Putin was going to cut off some gas and
certain oil and oil price would go up
and by the way for the climate folks
here it's made the climate worse because
people have this bad assumption that
high oil prices and gas prices reduce
consumption reduce CO2 no poor Nations
India China Indonesia Philippines
Vietnam are turning back on coal plants
as our Rich Nations called Germany
Netherlands France we have it completely
backwards and in my view America should
have been pumping more oil and gas and
it should have been supported you know
we're trying to have our cake and eat it
too a little bit okay so before I get to
JB diamond and it's like man it's just
obvious like again some of this is so
obvious in politics when someone is just
reading talking points often reading
them poorly off a teleprompter for
someone that is an expert in their field
you may not like Jamie dimon all of his
uh decisions related to what he's done
with JP Morgan or whatever but it's like
the guy obviously knows he's doing but
before I get to that I tried to write
out a bill what was it a billion
trillion times 50 million and I ran out
of room on the paper it's just it's just
a lot of zeros I don't know what this
number is but I'm pretty sure it's not
even the number that Joe just had that
much money people we could fix this
thing anyway Diamond makes a couple
interesting points one of the problems
that we have in America is that we have
an extremely myopic view of the world
that if only we just gave more money to
climate we could fix the whole thing as
Diamond points out you know these other
countries in other parts of the world
India China with all of these people you
know there's a lot of people in India
and China and they're going through
their industrial revolutions you know
currently while we did it you know say
50 60 70 years ago they're turning too
cold now so we could do everything we
could do everything you could never use
a plastic straw again and I hate those
freaking you know what I'm talking about
those those cardboard straws and then
have you been to the places where they
have the the pasta ones they I've been
to a place I think I think it was was
Italy maybe where they had the pasta
straw so it works for a couple sucks and
then you're just sucking on a wet noodle
is that what you people want you see
what I'm saying that's the future that
Joe Biden wants everyone's going to be
sucking on wet noodles your water tastes
like pasta
calm down Dave okay the point is that
whether we do everything that AOC and
Joe Biden wants and whether we wreck our
economy in the name of green energy and
all of those things not only will it not
fix anything it will harm our economy
and the rest of the world will still be
using coal and fossil fuels and all of
this stuff so it's just like it's just
the fact that Diamond's even saying this
knowing that he is one of the guys that
Biden is always referencing Biden is
always my my buddy he says it all the
time my buddy my friend Jamie Diamond he
even said this
well I have a feeling that Joe Biden if
he's awake right now he's not too
thrilled uh with uh Mr Jamie Diamond
anyway let's uh let's continue because
uh Jake Tapper asked some other
hard-hitting questions to the elderly
man pretending to be president he asked
him about our recession or not recession
or is it a recession midterm elections
are four weeks from today the economy
remains top top of mind for voters J.P
Morgan Chase CEOs of the U.S is likely
to enter a recession in the next nine
months Bank of America says the U.S
could start losing 175 000 jobs a month
gas prices are on the rise again
should the American people prepare for a
recession no look they've been saying
this now how every every six months they
say this every six months they look down
the next six months and see what's going
to happen it hadn't happened yet it
hadn't been there there has there is no
there's no guarantee that they're going
to be I don't think there will be a
recession if it is it'll be a very
slight recession that is we'll move down
slightly well look think about what's
happened we have done more we're in a
better position than any other major
country in the world economically and
politically we are we still have real
problems but we look look what we got
done we we passed so much legislation
that significantly makes a makes a point
about you know for example the American
Rescue plan the legislation to deal with
inflation the the inflation act we've
moved along I mean there's so much
that's been accomplished that the idea
that there's something there's an
automaticity to recession it's just not
it's just not there they keep they've
been predicting this off and on for the
last but you just said that a slight
recession is possible it is possible
look it's possible I don't anticipate it
oh he doesn't anticipate it much like
treasury secretary Janet Yellen hoped we
weren't going to be in a recession okay
so technically so first off everything
he said there is nonsense every single
thing he said there is nonsense or a
confusion or obfuscation of the truth
first off we technically are in a
recession right now A recession by every
definition until the last month was two
negative quarters back-to-back quarters
of reduction in the GDP we've already
hit that tomorrow we will find out if it
is a third quarter so we're already in
one whether he calls it a little one or
a tiny one or a teeny tiny little bitty
recession we are still in a recession it
just is and then he talks about you know
it's funny he called it the inflation
act he forgot to say reduction it was
called the inflation reduction act but
he actually was kind of honest there in
his muddled nonsense it's the inflation
act because the inflation reduction act
which was just the government spending a
[ __ ] ton of money to devalue the dollar
thus pushing us further into a recession
everyone knows this and this is one of
those things you don't need a high level
analyst to tell you that things are not
going well with the economy all you have
to do is try to buy a product and see
how long it takes and how much it costs
and our gas prices high and all of these
things like there are basic truths that
you can figure out without a lot of uh
you know Poli SCI going into it but
speaking of high level analysis uh here
is noted black lesbian Korean
Jean-Pierre who yesterday spent most of
her time on at the podium telling her
coming out story because it was National
Coming Out day although I'm pretty sure
every other day is National coming out
there you guys have anything to tell me
by the way
nothing got nothing out of these two uh
anyway Karen John Pierre here she is uh
just this is just sort of General
nonsense related to Biden in the economy
director of research with their report
their Global report came out he said
that the three largest economies in the
world the U.S China and the Eurozone
will stall will stall next year and so
I'm wondering if the president Bears any
responsibility with his policies for the
inflation and and what they're calling
installing it on but okay we got to step
back here and look at what the president
walked into here right when you think
about the night the we've been here for
about 20 months when he walked in
businesses were closed small businesses
were closing down schools were not open
and we were in an appendix and during a
pandemic or at the beginning of a
pandemic where thousands of people were
dying that's what the president walked
into what he did is put forth the
American Rescue plan which by the way
was only voted by democrats that was
able to turn back on our economy again
it's just it's always dancing around the
truth with them they cannot say anything
true like really honest and true uh is
it true that we were in a pandemic when
Biden came in yeah and is it true that
the economy was hurting yeah who was it
that was mostly locking people down who
was it that was mostly making sure that
people couldn't go to work and that
schools were closed it was Democrats it
was democrat-run cities it was
democrat-run States the few bash
bastions of Freedom where they kept
things open and they let people make
decisions for themselves and they kept
kids in school where they weren't going
to be infected you know why is it that
we didn't have one insane out break of
covid at a scary Floridian school why
didn't that happen
I don't know she also talks about the
thousands and thousands of deaths that
were happening before Biden we pulled
the numbers uh Trump uh you know how
many people died under Trump in the same
amount of time so covet was you know a
year plus with Trump uh 400 000. you
know how many have died since Biden has
taken over from Co from covet and of
course these numbers when they tell you
someone died from covid usually it's
because they tripped when they fell into
a ditch somewhere and then they also had
covet but anyway 500 000 people have
died from covid under Biden 400 under
Trump uh
Biden had also tweeted when he was
running for president that if anyone if
if you had that many people had died
that the person's not worthy of being
president so he should probably step
down anyway the point is
it's all nonsense out of these people
she knows that the economy is not good
and then what they always do the same
thing because Biden did it in that
interview right there which is but we
passed the inflation reduction act we
did all this stuff yes we agree you are
doing bad stuff guys there's a real
shitty problem here we got a real
problem with something well we signed
our name on something could somebody
give us credit for signing our name on
something we put our names on a piece of
paper and did something that doesn't
mean what you did was good but that's
what they're really good at we called it
the inflation reduction act guys it
obviously is reducing inflation
yeah anyway so the point is between
Ukraine sort of spinning out of control
between the economy deflating between
the fact that nobody thinks that Biden
is competent and all that stuff well
what are they going to do because we got
about three weeks before the midterms
what are they going to do
yeah you got it they're gonna call us
racist when a Democrat says something
racist or anti anti-Semitic we would
we hold them we hold Democrats
accountable when a mega Republican says
something racist and or anti-semitic
they are embraced by cheering crowds and
become celebrated and sought after
endorsements Senator tuberville let's
not forget this just happened saying
black people commit crimes
okay so first off no the Democrats do
not call out racism and anti-Semitism
ilhan Omar and Rashida talibar literally
the two biggest let's say Jew haters I
don't like the word anti-Semitism like
they have an obsession with that tiny
little country that Jews live in they
don't care whether hate crimes are up
against Jews and blah blah blah it
doesn't fit into the intersectional
calculator the Democrats they're the
ones that are importing all of the
racism the neo-racism of equity and
making sure that we discriminate against
Asian people and that people get jobs
based on skin color and all those things
so they are the modern racist the idea
that people are being applauded at
Republican rallies for saying racist or
anti-semitic things uh you did your
homework last night right did we find
any video on that we could not find any
videotape on that now we'll keep looking
for those moments where someone at a
republican rally says something racist
and is applauded she references
tuberville there saying that black
people commit crimes
um yeah you know it is true that people
of all colors commit crimes
um and sometimes that includes black
people so you know saying that say black
people are shooting black people in
Chicago and nobody cares about it
um that is not racist but every time a
republic you know they'll go crazy if a
white cop shoots a black person we can
burn down a city destroy Pep Boys take
it out at your local Target uh you know
if a black guy shoots 10 people in
Chicago you talk about that you racist
anyway it continues on the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC here's
uh correspondent David jolly
what you're seeing is where we thought
they would be going into November being
able to run solely on inflation it's not
fully working and so in Republican
Politics the issue of crime and the
issue of immigration have long been
proxies for race for playing the race
card for trying to scare voters to vote
Republicans because of the encroachment
of black and brown people
you see the way they frame it you see
that oh man I love it because once you
see it you'll never unsee it in
Republican politics if you care about
immigration or crime that's code for
racism if you don't want just thousands
and thousands actually it's over 2
million people just bashing through the
Border in this calendar year alone
you're a racist if you don't want
Grandma to be mugged and raped by a gang
of lunatics while trying to get on the
New York City subway you're a racist
that's why they talk about these things
because they're racist it's not because
they want law and order or they want to
be able to go to the store without being
mugged or raped or peed on or whatever
else is going on in New York City and
other democrat-run cities It's really
because they're racist and it's code for
racism duh
more from MSNBC boy we're really
bludgeoning these people today uh this
is Andrea Mitchell and Kimberly Atkins
uh running you know basically explaining
how Republicans are scaring the hell out
of you has this become normalized among
Republican leaders because they're so
eager to win the Senate
has been normalized and of course we've
seen the former president using uh
racist uh language to to describe
describe black and brown people as
criminals for years now ever since the
2016 election so it also isn't new but
it's of a piece with what we're seeing
across state not everybody is using as
patently racist language as Tommy
toberville but even in that debate uh
but in Ohio between uh JD Vance and Tim
Ryan we saw JD Vance harping on the
issue of crime and talking and linking
it to things like illegal immigration
those are the types of issues the things
that drive fear among voters that
Republicans think they have been very
successful with in the past
goes freaking Republicans always harping
on crime now it's interesting what she's
talking about there we showed you the
clip of this yesterday actually is that
there was this uh 10 year old girl in
Ohio who was raped by an illegal
immigrant so it brought up the issue of
both abortion and illegal immigration JD
Vance basically said if we would do
something about the Border then we
wouldn't have illegals here in here
raping 10 year olds yeah
but these freaking Republicans just
because it's not safe in your community
and occasionally they burn down all the
stores and they mug people left and
right and they defund the police just
because they do you don't have to say it
you're racist it's so stupid it's so
extraordinarily stupid by the way please
somebody and again Phoenix I want you to
get to your computer after this I want
to find all that racist talk that Donald
Trump was always doing because that's
what she's referring to right there you
may remember Donald Trump in his State
of the Union talking about lowest
all-time black unemployment and the
Congressional Black August
sitting there like this because we don't
like you orange man even if our people
have more jobs
ridiculous uh so what is their last shot
as the economy goes down which they're
in charge of and as Ukraine seems to
spin out of control well I suppose we
could always bring back covet and we are
carefully monitoring the rise of several
sub-variants that are evolving rapidly
and emerging around the world including
ones that evade some of our treatments
guys the subvariants are coming and our
vaccine that doesn't work
it still maybe isn't going to work and
there's oh lordy lordy the fact that
they're even discussing this again is so
grotesque and is such a dereliction of
all of their duties and all of they have
is fear and everything else uh this is a
great segue actually to a an incredible
story that mainstream is barely going to
touch uh this is a member of European
Parliament his name is Rob Roos and he
is full on exposing the Pfizer director
uh and showing that the vaccine was
never tested for transmissibility
meaning it was never tested to see if
once you were waxed whether you were
going to send kovid to someone else oh
but six feet and masks and all that take
a look at this it's incredible
if you don't get vaccinated you're
anti-social this is what the Dutch prime
minister and health Minister told us you
don't get vaccinated just for yourself
but also for others you do it for all of
society that's what I said
today this turned out to be complete
nonsense
in a covert Hearing in the European
Parliament one of the Pfizer directors
just admitted to me at the time of
introduction the vaccine had never been
tested on stopping the transmission of
the virus
and I will speak in English so there are
no misunderstandings
was the Pfizer covet vaccine tested on
stopping the transmission of the virus
before it entered the market
if not please say it clearly if yes are
you willing to share the data with this
committee and I really want a straight
answer yes or no and I'm looking forward
to it thank you very much
regarding the question around
um did we know about stop and
humanization before it's entered the
market no these
um you know we had to really move at the
speed of science to really understand
what is taking place in the market
wow we had to move at the speed of
science we had to get new freaks to
inject yourselves with our fake vaccine
in essence fake vaccine because that it
would be the only way we would know what
it would do to you
would it have side effects would it work
would you have heart problems how the
hell are we supposed to know we got to
get that [ __ ] out to you you gotta
inject yourself with it and if you don't
we're also going to make sure that you
can't work and you can't be part of
polite society and up in Canada maybe it
will freeze your bank accounts or not
let you out of the country that is so
incredible what just happened there
it's so incredible I'm actually almost
speechless they did not know whether the
vaccine which was being mandated and
forced on all of us and shutting down
the world for two years they did not
know whether it was going to stop people
from giving covid to other people and it
turns out it didn't even stop people
from getting covered themselves it is
actually incredible uh so here now is a
video compilation of Pfizer CEO Albert
borla and this guy if there is Justice
in the world will end up in jail but
he's made a [ __ ] ton of money over the
last couple years and was and was
treated like a king and brought on every
news show and everything else this is a
compilation video over time of him
basically admitting that the vaccines
don't work this is really incredible a
lot of indications right now that are
telling us that there is a protection
against transmission of the disease
there is no barrier that we have
identified that escapes the protection
of our vaccines to come now with the
treatment of 90 effectiveness you know
personally makes me a lot very proud
about it and we know that um the three
the two dose of the vaccine offer very
limited protection if any the three
doses with a booster
they offer reasonable protection against
it is necessary a Ford boost right now
the protection that you are getting from
the third it is good enough actually
quite good for hospitalizations and
deaths is not that good against
infections but that's a lot man we
really should call this the speechless
show because what else can I add to this
do you get that that by the way is
there's a guy on Twitter it's maze more
you see his watermark on there we show
his videos off and he's doing great work
but like
that guy should be in jail
and that woman who was testifying should
probably be in jail too these people
should not be members of polite or even
impolite Society anymore they forced
millions and millions of people all over
the world to get injected with something
that they don't know exactly what it did
nor exactly what it might do to you
after and we'll get to that in just a
moment but when you watch that video
that oh it works perfectly it works
absolutely perfect it works about 90
percent oh you know you're gonna need
two and what was the line if at all he
says was it if at all if at all no
fourth booster and you guys you're not
going to believe this or when these
people get these vaccines and boosters
and everything someone has to pay for it
whether it's you privately out of your
pocket or insurance company or or a
government and uh yeah Pfizer's stock is
going to go through the roof and oh yeah
that guy just happens to own a lot of
the stock
here in Florida we have some sane people
uh and uh I was going to say at the top
of the list but since we have a lot
there's a there's a big top here uh on
the list of sane people our Surgeon
General is a guy I've mentioned him a
couple times before I think we're going
to get him on the show soon hopefully uh
Surgeon General Dr Joseph latipo he
joined the DeSantis Administration in
the middle of covid and Governor
DeSantis has repeatedly said it was one
of the best decisions he ever made
because it gave him the confidence to go
ahead and make sure that they weren't
going to lock down and kick kids out of
school and shut everybody down and all
of that stuff well latipo went on Tucker
a day or two ago uh referencing a study
that the State of Florida did uh talking
about how or the study was looking into
what the repercussions were going to be
after especially young men took the
vaccine
so I ask people sometimes who are still
you know hemming and hawing about this
if this if this vaccine if it had been
known two years ago or so that this
vaccine would increase cardiac death in
young men by 84 would they have approved
it the obvious answer is no you would
never give something to someone who was
young and healthy and increase their
risk of dying from cart from Sudden
cardiac death by 84 percent but people
are often their response is well you
know I don't know covet's pretty bad yes
covet can be terrible but we don't give
people medications that kill them
yeah we that's generally not what
medications are for to kill you uh but
there is this Mass 84 84 right like this
is this is not these are not small
numbers that we're dealing with here uh
as you may remember from our show a day
or two ago I think it was yesterday
actually
um latapo posted this he posted the full
paper the full research paper on Twitter
he was then banned from Twitter it was
only after pushback that they let him
back on but the real question is whether
they Shadow ban it or don't let people
see it or why was he banned in the first
place
etc etc
um but if you knew that there would be
this spike in heart issues with young
men who are otherwise healthy would you
have gotten the vaccine and now knowing
that they didn't even know what the
vaccine did and when you watch that
video of the Pfizer CEO over time
admitting that none of this [ __ ] worked
the the ha I mean how much more do I
have to put on a silver plate for you
people so the the fact is guys we've got
two choices in November and it's it's
same or insane right it's does sanity or
complete Insanity that's really where
we're at and they are going to scare the
hell out of you if you think that what
they've done with covid and lockdowns in
Ukraine and nuclear they have to ramp it
all up now they have to because there's
nothing else and by the way
let me say I I and I often say this but
I would love if there was something else
imagine if there were a whole bunch of
sane Democrats that maybe I disagreed
with on their their scope of what the
government should do or what taxation
was or whatever but they really were
there to try to fix problems and not
just lie about everything Not only would
I love to have them on the show I think
we could find common ground and it would
be all good that actually is sort of
what my conversation with Bill Maher was
all about right we're kind of within 30
percent of all of these things now I I
think over time I can perhaps move Bill
a little more to our side let's say and
hopefully he'll he'll stop voting for
the people who do all this stuff but the
point is there's nobody left everyone
top down whether it's this Pfizer CEO
whether it's the president of the United
States the spokesman for these people
the people who are coming up with the
vaccines they have lied about absolutely
everything so all they can do is ramp it
up make it seem like racists are coming
to get you and they're going to drop a
nuclear bomb on your head and everything
else oh and of course that they're going
to steal more elections and democracy
must be safe saved because a couple
grandmas wandered into the capitol a
couple years ago here's msnbc's Nicole
Wallace using fear recently I started by
asking if we'd ever been here before is
because I think as a country we all have
to participate in it because if you have
kids your kids wake up if you have
anything to do with an election if
you're an election worker or a news
anchor and they want to know what
happened and I think we have to have a
conversation as a country
about how we might not know the next
morning what happened we might not know
the day after that and that is their
point
that is their point they're not all
running to win some of them will
Unfortunately they are running to sew
Discord in America and it will change
everything we will wake up the morning
after election day we might not even
call it that anymore in two years we
might not call it election day we might
call it election week because what we
are watching and because it's so slow
it's so slow we don't cover it as a five
alarm fire but it is we are watching
Republicans not just destroying
democracy in the dark breaking into
election officers and plugging stuff in
we're watching them do it from rally
stages debate stages that's where
they're doing it and and I guess
the reason I asked you if we'd been here
before is do you think it requires you
know a democracy commission should
should President Obama ask Chris
Christie and Ben Ginsburg to sort of man
a democracy hotline the way you know
people used to man other crises I mean
what should we do
well um it it doesn't take a commission
it just takes Republicans that have some
character and integrity standing up
guys if I heard Nicole Wallace correctly
Republicans broke into something and
plugged something in
I don't know what it was it could have
been an iPhone charger no idea
they could have been recharging their
vibrator I don't know
Republicans don't have vibrators what
kind of show is this look I don't know
what the hell of Republicans
plugged in in this place that they broke
into but they're running to sow Discord
is what she says and and if you saw the
Chiron on that they were mostly talking
about the Arizona race the Arizona race
which we've talked a lot about here and
I've had Blake Masters on the show Blake
is a freaking decent dude he is a friend
he opened for me at my Arizona show my
Phoenix show when I was on the book tour
I know him rather well I've been to some
of the fundraisers he cares about his
family he's got three young kids he
cares about the Border
um he even although as he mentions he
has a personal belief that is pro-life
but he's willing to make a 15-week
compromise he doesn't want illegals
running all over the place like but he's
running to sew Discord that's what they
want that's what they want you to think
they just want you to think that we're
all racist we're all mean and then
what's gonna happen what's going to
happen on the day after the election you
know and this is not to excuse anyone
that did anything illegal on January 6th
it really is not you are allowed to
peacefully protest of course and the
cops were letting people in there's oh
the whole thing is a cluster or F of
insanity but what do you think is going
to happen the day after the election if
there's a red sweep and the entire
machine from Colbert and of course you
know it starts with Biden in the
administration and and all their
spokespeople calling everyone racist and
mean and all that and fascists but then
you know Colbert Nicole Wallace MSNBC
CNN New York Times well if they've for
now two years well it's many more than
two years but the two years of Biden
Administration but you go four years
before that and you could probably even
go before that if they've run around
calling everybody racist and now the
racists are in charge you think they
might bring back that summer of love you
think this explains why it turns out
that liberals have far more mental
disorders than conservatives because
they have them completely Bamboozled in
an imaginary world of their own mind so
who are these Republicans that they're
talking about these mean Republicans
well I I live in a pretty red state that
I'm sure is about to get way redder when
we have our gubernatorial election in a
couple weeks and things are going pretty
well here I see black people and white
people walking down the street together
often in Harmony singing songs
everybody's happy here the economy is
chugging along but so there must be mean
Republicans these and they and they all
must be just so mean and all that stuff
well uh we found this video about a very
mean Republican I get asked all the time
who is Ron DeSantis well he's the kid
who grew up right here in Florida
working his tail off paying his own way
through school then volunteering to
serve in the Navy and deploying to Iraq
he's the man who I fell in love with
from the moment we met and he's the dad
of three very rambunctious energetic
children maybe our two-year-old little
comedian Madison our beautiful sweet
five-year-old and Mason our
four-year-old athlete but if you want to
know who Ron DeSantis really is when I
was diagnosed with cancer and I was
facing the battle for my life
he was the dad who took care of my
children when I couldn't
he was there to pick me off of the
ground when I literally could not stand
he was there to fight for me when I
didn't have the strength to fight for
myself
that is who run DeSantis is
pretty scary pretty scary this guy
and these Republicans just kind of want
to limit government a little bit let you
make choices for yourself not force you
to get injected with things that don't
work
they are scary they are racist
the choice is yours people I'm just
trying to lay it out for a couple weeks
before the election that it's just going
to get crazier and just stay cool stay
calm stay collected and uh as as the
girls say we got this uh stick around
for a cold close but let's get to some
comments from the locals Community EK
says the mainstream media can't think
without a government-sponsored
teleprompter isn't it true it's just
like when you watch Colbert go off on
Elon Musk because he's talking about
peace whether you think his peace idea
is bad or not but he goes off on him and
the implication that he's a Russian
agent or when you see just two days
before that he brings on fauci and they
laugh and they make jokes about how
fauci doesn't want kids to cough on him
despite being 18 times vax and fauci
also got covet a few times during that
so he should have some antibodies and
all of those things it's like yeah they
can't do any of this without a
teleprompter of course you know you
watch Corinne Jean Pierre you watch
Biden one of the things we didn't show
you because I just thought it would be a
little gratuitous is during that
interview with Jake Tapper Biden's notes
actually fall off his lap
I don't know why he has notes shouldn't
he just know what he's talking about be
able to sit there and have an interview
right you have you out of notes if
you're the interviewer so you can get to
the questions you want to get to maybe
you need to know some numbers but his
notes literally fell out of his lap and
tap or picked him up for him uh e says
Colbert isn't even funny how is he still
on the air well it's exactly what I've
been talking about he gives the machine
what it wants and then the thing is when
you give the machine what you want at
some point the machine will just be done
with you because the machine will go on
that's that's sort of what I would call
like the Brian stelter effect right
stelter never did anything honest didn't
hold the media to account was a Democrat
activist was all for all of the bad
ideas and then finally enough people
were like yeah this potato is ridiculous
this is a ridiculous this is a
ridiculous baked potato uh and then the
machine's just like yeah we're done with
you but then what happens because
Democratic privilege is the only
privilege that truly exists in the
United States he gets a gig teaching
about media at Harvard
you can't make it up math says nuclear
bomb drills will be the new form of
lockdowns yeah I think there's some
version of that that is probably right
let's not forget kids that grew up you
know only what is it 50 60 70 years ago
during World War II uh we're told I mean
I remember my dad telling me about this
when they were in elementary school and
you know they would tell you what to do
in case of nuclear fallout and stand in
between the the door and get under your
desk and all of that stuff hint it
doesn't work
um yes they will try to scare the hell
out of people with that just like they
use lockdowns they will also try to tell
you that climate change if you keep
using your car and you keep eating meat
and all of these things that you are
going to destroy the environment and
just guys just give them more of your
money give them more of your money and
more of your resources and don't do
stuff that makes you happy don't worry
they'll be eating wagyu they're going to
get the Japanese A5 which is it's like
butter it really is if you get a nice
Japanese I'm going to get one for you
guys I usually do the filet mignon with
you guys we smoke it I'm gonna get a
nice Japanese A5 I'm telling you it's so
buttery you can only eat one piece
You're Gonna Love It guys don't forget
to like And subscribe to all of our
channels especially
reubenrumble.com reubenreport and
reubenreport.com locals part one of my
interview with Megan Kelly is up across
platforms to fold things up at locals
right now and we leave you with a cold
close juxtaposing the orange man and the
elderly man
if you're a middle class family you're
getting hurt badly right now you're
sitting at the kitchen table this
morning deciding well we can't get new
tires of their ball because we have to
wait another month or so talk about
North Korea
10 seconds Mr President 10 seconds
let's get off this China thing and then
he looks the family around the table
everything just the typical politician
when I see that let's talk about a
typical politician okay that's why I got
elected come on Joe you can do better
I grew up in a family
where when the price of gasoline went up
at the pump it was a conversation at the
kitchen table with my dad where prices
went up for things were daily
requirements like the gallon of gasoline
it became a discussion of the kitchen
table it mattered Felder it was a
discussion of the kitchen table you felt
it was a discussion at the kitchen table
around your kitchen table on our kitchen
table felt at the kitchen table on the
kitchen table and around our kitchen
tables around the kitchen table in the
morning to feel it in your own lives
around the kitchen table talk about
around your kitchen table I learned that
at the kitchen table in Scranton my dad
used to say the end of the day it's just
when you sit at that table come on Joe
you could do better we're going to talk
about North Korea now